how do you like you look we watch
Entourage and we you know vicariously
live through you guys right we would
watch them and say um I relate to him I
relate to him I relate to him he's this
guy and everybody was somebody right I'm
this I'm this I'm that
putting the crew together where in a
competitive world like you what are some
quarterly qualities you look at to say
I'm gonna let this guy be in my inner
circle because listen
many of us have a lot of acquaintances
we have a lot of friends you must have a
lot of friends but then there is the
inner circle of three or five names what
especially in the industry you're in
what qualities do you look at to say
this guy is one of the guys that's in
the Inner Circle well I know for me um
and I and I always say like I mean I
mean this from the bottom of my heart
and I I do believe
one person's success doesn't will never
hurt mine in fact the opposite right so
if something good happens to a friend of
mine and success for them is
I've never ever ever had a bit of not
even one bit of jealousy for my inner
circle of friends that have done really
great things because I don't know it
just was never it just was never in my
heart because it doesn't have anything
to do with with me that some there's
there's enough room for everybody
um so yeah and and it's it's I I got
lucky we you know we kind of grew up in
a circle uh of people that have gone on
to be successful but everybody's kind of
had their own sort of path to it
um and the other thing about when you
have super successful friends like that
is that they keep you grounded right and
when when you see how well they handle
situations
and they're at the highest of high
levels you go well you see it and then
you see somebody else
acting out or misbehaving like you know
what it doesn't have to be that way
because I know people that are
10 times bigger than you and would never
do that
you know so it doesn't have to be the
way of stomping your feet and yelling
and screaming you can be a good guy and
and you know accomplish great things but
by the way that's a powerful statement
you just made right the fact that a
father we were talking about this
yesterday if other people are winning
you don't need to be envious about it
you just do celebrate their success yeah
it's good for you yeah Ethan and I were
talking when he was on the Ethan Supply
we're talking on a podcast and I asked
some questions about different people
he's worked with and I said who's the
hardest working guy you work with he
says Leonardo DiCaprio the way he works
is he's the number one professional I've
never been late he says I've only been
late one time he told the story in his
entire time of working he says but Leo
it's early he always knows the lines
he's this he's that he's this so for us
like we put an event together like this
right the only thing everybody sees is
from the drape here nobody says what's
going on there nobody said what's going
on there yeah it's a lot of stuff that's
going on behind closed doors we see the
movie on the big screen when we go there
right
with a lot of people that you work with
the guys that made it to the top level
that you're friends with what what is
the difference between how they handle
because sometimes you know like wow that
guy's just probably very talented that's
why he made it to the top you know it's
just purely talented he's got these
god-given abilities what do you see that
we don't see behind closed doors I mean
I've I've had the pleasure of working
with some some really talented people
and um they all have one thing in common
and it's the work ethic you know and and
their their commitment to the to their
craft and
um I don't want to say I'm friends with
them but I I did do a few I did two
movies with Denzel Washington
um I did John Q with denz Allen
one of my favorite movies about I don't
think I've seen John Q or not you know I
heard I think I've heard you oh man I
love I mentioned Man on Fire today but
John Q is a very emotional movie yeah
yeah and I you know I don't you know
like I I play a nurse right so I'm in a
lot of scenes but I'm not doing things
that are terribly challenging but to
have a front row seat to watch Denzel
Washington perform at that level it was
like I'm driving home like maybe this
just isn't for me
no let's go try to go back
I'm never doing that right I mean just
like and I don't want to say it was easy
but just I just I had not ever seen
anything that up close I mean there's
the scene where he's like got the gun to
his head and I'm and I'm like bandaging
his arm I'm doing nothing but I had a
front row seat to him um just throwing
up a a veto I mean it was just a massive
game I was like whoa I couldn't I like I
said I hadn't seen that with my own eyes
but if you look at Denzel you know he
started on the stage and he does the
theater and he's and he's just an actors
actor you know so
um but again it all comes it comes down
to the hard work and everybody has a
different process Leo's process is deep
he's deep he goes you know yeah he's
prepared you're not gonna you're not
gonna see him flipping through a script
between between takes yeah no he's the
work is already done for those guys when
they get there
foreign
[Music]